Well, Andy, I mentioned
this earlier this week,
but let's face it, you and I
are pretty big trivia buffs.
Yeah, we played a trivia
game earlier this week,
it was fun.
We sure did.
Now, the first time we played,
your questions were a little intense,
I just wanna make sure
this time you understand
it's just a friendly, simple
trivia competition, okay?
(chuckling) Conan, I already told you
there is nothing friendly about trivia.
Whatever, let's go, Richter.
All right, let's do it.
(suspenseful music)
All right, here it goes.
Who had the starring role
in the 2014 sci-fi adventure
movie "Interstellar"?
Matthew McConaughey.
Correct.
All right, all right,
all right. (chuckling)
You and your spot-on impressions.
Thank you, thank you.
Classic.
All right, my turn.
(clearing throat) You ready?
[Conan] Yep.
The RMS Lusitania was a
British ocean liner launched
in 1906 that made many
transatlantic crossings
before it was torpedoed
and sunk by a German U-boat
during World War I.
Okay, actually I know quite
a bit about World War I,
I'm a history fan, so--
What are the current longitude
and latitude coordinates
of the RMS Lusitania shipwreck?
Andy, that's like, just like last time,
that, no one knows the
answer to that question.
It's way too complicated.
They're just coordinates, Conan.
I mean, don't you know
how the ocean works?
I know how the ocean works,
just give me a simple question.
All right, here you go, easy peasy.
What color--
Ah, so far, so good.
Was the building
that served New Zealand's
first cable tramway line
that opened in 1881?
Oh, Andy, come on.
It's called trivia 'cause
the questions are supposed
to be trivial, simple, fun.
Oh my God, okay, I'll give
you a real simple one.
Which 5G carrier is fast,
reliable, and secure?
Why, that's AT&T 5G.
(chuckling) That's right, Conan.
It's not complicated.
Indeed, AT&T 5G is a no-brainer.
It's a no-brainer.
It's not complicated.
(laughing)